né en tunisie ces cartouches d'une
famille modeste plutôt modeste et
tunisienne d'origine madame à ce que non
d'origine française italienne tunisienne
tunisienne est ce que je puis vous
demander en quoi cette question a de
l'importance est ce que si j'étais
vraiment tu disais je n'aurais pas le
droit de vous parler des fois ça n'est
pas ça va bien je suis la plus fière des
réalisations que je voulais avoir où il
vient je la donne très volontiers mon
père s'est fait naturaliser français
avec ma mère mon père était un grand
admirateur de la france et il s'est fait
naturaliser quand je vais je crois 54,5
en est et dans ce cas là le décret de
naturalisation englobe l'épousé les
enfants mineurs donc mon frère et mes
moi même je suis devenu français
il vous préférez rester tunisienne en
cas oublier le libre choix probablement
probablement parce que j'ai été très
intégrée enfin à la lutte de ce pays
encore qu'elles étaient relativement
courte c'est plutôt dans la bataille
d'alger greek j'ai pris la plus grande
part aujourd'hui si vous me posez la
question je me demande si finalement je
ne suis pas plus algérienne que
tunisienne compte tenu que j'ai donné
presque huit ans de ma vie à la cause de
l'indépendance algérienne
là je n'ai pas eu le choix cela dit faut
quand même dire que je suis profondément
de culture française mais de culture
absolument je veux dire je n'ai pas pris
je parle l'arabe mais je l'appris non
dans les rues mais de couleur pas de
l'agriculture africaine de coeur je suis
aussi france oui la culture française si
vous voulez j'ai eu un petit coup si
j'ose dire à régler avec elle parce que
j'avais une telle admiration pour la
france et tout ce qu'on y apprend toute
la france pour moi c'était ce que
j'apprenais à l'école et la l'école
colonisés par conséquent ça ne pouvait
pas mettre son lieu noël blanc et puis
le noël
je n'avais jamais vu de neige de ma vie
et puis c'était la patrie des droits de
l'homme l'égalité la justice et puis je
me suis trouvé brusquement parce que
j'étais encore très jeune quand même
jetés là dans les facultés de droit en
particulier ou où on m'a fait on de mes
origines j'ai appris que le racisme
existe et alors que je pensais que ça
pouvait exister en tunisie même parce
que là il ya les mauvais français
l'écolo en arrive en france les français
aussi l'ont été et puis après il ya eu
cette abominable chose pour moi que je
combattrai toute ma vie d'angleur et les
forces en tout cas c'était la torture et
la tare hollande hurleurs tueries dans
les deux camps la torture je ne parle du
camp dans lequel j'ai été me battre
mahdaoui j'étais là d'un cadeau fiscal
lg retenir les deux camps là dans les
deux camps l'adoration par espèce la
torture était érigée en système et vous
étonne d'ailleurs que vous puissiez pour
tester parce que personne y compris le
général massu quelqu un certain nombre
de livres là dessus il sait de quoi il
parle d'un massue l'a dit alors la
personne ne le conteste ce que je veux
dire j'en viens à moi en plaidant ses
affaires je suis venu dire au tribunal
mais on m'a appris des choses à l'école
française qui étaient fausses qui a
menti
est ce vous est ce que la france et la
torture est ce que la france est ce que
j'ai appris à l'école
alors il faut m'expliquer si vous étiez
vraiment très avide absolue je ne sais
pas si c'est être à vide absolu que de
combattre inconditionnellement la
torture madame où qu'elle se trouve
moi mon poste c'était le tribunal
militaire en algérie
je me suis battu au détriment de ma
liberté physique puisque lui même été
arrêté pour surfer très posé une
question à m aligne pourquoi êtes vous
attaché à défendre les intérêts des
algériens parce que très tôt voyez vous
c'est en ça que j'ai une certaine comme
environ sérénité non
choix j'ai l'impression que les choix
que j'ai fait quand j'étais toute petite
fille dix ans ils sont les mêmes
aujourd'hui quand je me bats pour les
femmes très tôt j'ai eu le sentiment
parce que j'ai vécu d'un monde coupé en
deux c'est un peu manichéisme et ça mais
quelquefois c'est pas mauvais de l'aide
pour y voir clair d'abord et bien j'ai
eu le sentiment très tôt j'ai constaté
qu'il y avait ceux qui oppriment et et
ceux qui étaient opprimés eux les riches
les pauvres ceux qui colonise est ce
qu'ils étaient colonisés en l'espèce
pour un con plus précisément ce que vous
me demandez en algérie il y avait une
colonisation ait eu un peuple algérien
qui étaient opprimés et exploités
surtout à qui on enlever ont refusé la
dignité d'exister en tant que peuple
vous voyez moi j'étais très sensible
je ne sais pas si je citais malraux mais
j'ai dû le faire sans le vouloir en
plaidant pour un algérien qui parlaient
pas le français et même pas l'arabe de
les réparer un espèce de patois des
montagnes il disait on me dit mais
pourquoi tu fais la guerre d'algérie
savait pas très bien et pourquoi
l'indépendance il connaissait pas très
bien ces mots là il dit avant je vivais
j'étais comme un ouvrier au père puis on
est venu me dire on m'a dit les frères
m'ont dit profuse yves à la montagne
pour quoi faire
pour l'indépendance mais seulement at il
dit j'ai pris un fusil et en gravissant
cette montagne dans le sud venu un homme
est alors qu'est ce que la dignité
d'homme et de c'est le contraire de
l'humiliation vous et je crois que un
peuple humilié est un peuple qui se
battra jusqu'au bout pour convaincre si
votre à dire quelque chose de précis je
vécu en algérie très longtemps mes
parents n'étaient installé depuis 50 ans
mon père était dans l'administration et
je n'ai jamais vu d'algériens opprimés
dans mon entourage
ah non non non j'allais chez eux
je prenais le thé à la menthe et je vous
assure qu'on était vraiment en
concordance on s'entendait très bien je
crois que là dessous il ya eu de la
politique j'ai mis le feu aux poudres
décision valable parce que les français
et les
j'ai rien s'entendait parfaitement alors
vous parlez des colons je vais vous
citer un cas en france et il y a des
usines ou les patrons sont des colons
c'est pas la peine de tourner autour du
pot il ya des colons en france et comme
il y en avait un en algérie puisque vous
les appelez des colons et bien que le
dit que le colon que le nid colonisateur
mais assez pour ça qu'aujourd'hui nous
n'avons plus de pétrole on leur a tout
laissé le reste bel et bien faire un
débat de ce soir moi je reviens les bacs
sur une guerre du moyen-orient
non j'ai vu que la dépendance de
l'algérie un manche veut bien parce que
moi il ya des éléments que j'aime bien
j'y ai laissé des amis je crois que
madame excusez-moi de vous interrompre
les doux je vais vous anticipez un petit
peu sur une mission que nous voulons
faire prochainement
alors alors spécial usa alors je
m'excuse
[Musique]